what else could be kind of a status
symbol i think i have a couple yeah i
think like the splitting time thing
between cities um it's still expensive
but it's one place it's still expensive
but it's not prohibitively expensive um
so like i think that that's going to be
uh far more con i'm doing it now and i
realize i'm like in a fortunate
situation but i think that it's far more
uh accommodating than ever before
uh so i think that like that part-time
living in in splitting time between
cities is gonna be quite common um
i don't know what else yeah i think
that's a great that's actually a great
one uh it's sort of like if you look at
what do our what do our rich friends do
now
that's not common and then that's just
gonna become like like more people are
gonna do that thing so like you know
like you're talking about having a few
either airbnbs or like having three
homes and just shift like throughout the
year just shifting based on where you
want to be in whatever season you want
to be in and not having like a hometown
um dude here's more of a thing here's
one and you're getting into it now i've
been into it for a minute as well which
is did you see
well kinda i tweeted out asking people
to see to say like what what like so i'm
i'm i'm building this house um and i'm
like how would you optimize it for
longevity health and fitness and i got
so many amazing replies and the most
consistent one was cold plunge and sauna
so many people are interested in that
and i think that that's a much bigger
trend than i ever thought so i think
having home saunas and in home cold tubs
that is something that's going to be
that's i think we're still in the early
stages of that i never would have
thought that that was going to be a
thing uh yeah that's the
i just bought a sauna by the way like
two days ago i know i saw you
what's his name andrew said like don't
do infrared and you're like uh but i
bought an infrared is that so okay yeah
uh by the way there's a sick company so
check this out is it uh david david's
company
florenz have you seen this this guy just
dm'd me who i'm friends with he spoke at
hustle again he goes hey i just met with
shawn about my sauna business and
he said this guy yeah and he said that
you also like this type of stuff have
you um did you go look at it did you see
it get sick uh he just he dm'd me a
video and you want to explain what it
was so basically
uh uh floor so there's two that that got
um
that got uh
they got kind of like highlighted here
um
where are you at the url is we are
florins um
how do you spell florins uh
f-l-o-r-e-n-s f-l-o-r-e-n-s
okay
um okay so basically we are florenz uh
so basically what he's done is he's
built a in a custom kind of like new
version of in-home sauna it plugs into a
normal normal outlet which when i was
looking up saunas that was like one big
thing it's like you have to i don't have
to get an electrician out here to handle
the power of the sauna it's like small
enough where it fits in uh it's like a
great like
like it's like made for like you know
one person can fit easily then there's a
super nice like super clean design so
like most saunas kind of look like this
kind of same cabin looking feel
this looks like it fits in like a modern
home it's like very slick looking um and
so he's building this thing and he
showed me one he's got it i'm gonna go
visit him he's got one down here not too
far from where i live
uh so then there's one then there's one
in the presidio called ancient ritual
have you seen this one that's the one i
saw ancient ritual so and so there's two
so ancient rituals the other one that
people are kind of hyping up and i think
that one is like almost like peloton for
asana so you get in normally when you
get into a sauna you're like on your own
it's like dude here go sit in this this
hot box and like think or you know talk
to the naked guy next to you like i
don't know like do whatever you want to
do
i think what ancient i don't know
exactly what ancient rituals doing but i
think what they're doing is it's sort of
like a guided meditations they have
sounds they have scents they have like
um they'll talk you through like what to
what to like it's like it's like calm or
like headspace like meets a sauna uh
that's my like prediction they're a
little bit they're very stealthy there's
like nothing on the website but that's
my understanding of it just from uh
figuring it out dude the florence thing
is amazing
yeah so i'm really excited about both of
these i don't think either of these just
like you know mega huge business
but i think it's
i think it could definitely be a really
healthy business um and it might be one
of those that surprises you maybe
there's bigger demand maybe this is
maybe this ends up like pools right like
i think um our buddies are in the they
bought a pool construction company he
was telling me something like
you know um
like some absurd percentage of homes
like uh 50 of homes or whatever in in
areas that can host a pool like will get
a pool in the suburbs and um
and it's like a it's
that's not the exact percentage but it's
like it's a 50 000 average ticket
um it's the number one like kind of like
optional upgrade to a house that that
happens and um and so you know those
companies are doing really well pool
construction companies and so maybe
if you fast forward 10 years down the
road sauna and cold plunge is going to
be as common as swimming pool is in
america like i could i could see a world
where that's the case
i definitely could too so um i'll have
to remember exactly what these the the
study says but there's a there was a
very reputable and famous study and it
said two interesting things the first
thing that it said was if you sauna for
two 20-minute sessions a week
it decreases the likelihood of
cardiovascular disease by something like
30 or 40 percent a massive number
then it said if you sauna for three
20-minute sessions
a week it's gonna decrease it by like 60
like it's like the numbers are like
astronomical just from two to three let
alone zero to two and so sauna's like i
i i the what the way it works is
basically like when your body heats up
that much
i guess it stresses it and that that's a
really healthy and good stress and uh
anyway it's pretty sick i'm all about
that